salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux savez vous que les volcans à la
surface de la planète sont classés en
deux catégories
cris dans la manière dont se déroulent
les éruptions certains sont vie effusif
on parle aussi de volcans rouge en
raison de la couleur de la lave dans ce
cas elle jaillit en forme en découler
qui serpente sur les flancs du volcan
comme une rivière de roches en fusion
ces volcans sont les moins dangereux car
la lave s'écoule lentement laissant le
temps aux populations de se mettre à
l'abri c'est le cas du kilauea hawaï qui
au passage est aussi le volcan le plus
actif du monde les autres volcans sont
dits explosifs comme leurs noms
l'indiquent ils sont à l'origine de
violentes explosions ils sont
extrêmement dangereux d'importants
volumes de gaz et de cendres
incandescentes sont projetées dans
l'atmosphère voilà pourquoi on parle
aussi de volcans gris ce nuage fini par
retomber au sol et dévale la pente à
toute allure détruisant tout sur son
passage
c'est ce qu'on appelle une nuée ardente
le vésuve en italie où le mont
saint-helens aux états unis figurent
parmi les volcans explosif